thank you all for the opportunity to be
here today a real pleasure to to talk to
this group from whom I always learn so
much i was asked actually today to to
make a sort of combined talk where where
i introduced the there are three related
talks will be hearing today and and if
kevin waitin Brown is here you might get
a fourth related talk at some point too
but let me just get started on what we
have here so the three related talks
today are one by me where I'm going to
give an introduction to the whole to the
whole set of things and then talk about
substitution metric talk by Ilya sagal
on privacy substitutes and optimization
and the talk by shenmue Leon obviously
strategy proof mechanism there's also
related work by Kevin Layton Brown these
are all motivated in part by in part by
many things but in part by work that's
being done on the so called us incentive
auction which is which I'll tell you
about now so the things that that set a
background for all of this hour this
this huge auction which is about to take
place that people estimate you know you
you read in the newspapers anywhere from
40 to 80 billion dollars worth of
transactions so it's going to be a
really enormous deal and it's just for
background so you know what we're
talking about this was something that
was conceived in 2010 where the National
Broadband Plan in the u.s. said that
Congress should consider expressly
expanding the FCC's authority to enable
it to conduct incentive auctions that's
where the term comes from in which
incumbent licensees may relinquish
spectrum rights to other parties or to
the FCC so that was proposed and there's
been a whole series of the spectrum act
in 2012 enabled this the there was a
notice of proposed rule in 2011 after
the National Broadband Plan but before
the spectrum auction I was hired by the
FCC to put together a team to begin
planning for this legislation came in
2012 a notice of proposed rulemaking
which proposed the design that the
auction amex team put together was was
proposed in 2012 it was adopted there
was a report in order in 2014 which
provide provided rules for the
implementation of the auction and most
recently on august sixth the the
procedures public notice was issued
which established the procedures for the
auction so this is going to happen first
bid will be on March 29th 2016 and the
consultants contract I'd like to put
this up because it's really daunting I
was asked to sign a contract in
September 2011 to put together a team
with these design goals listed for the
auction they wanted efficiency they
wanted the net revenues to be adequate
whatever that means minima the design
should minimize gaming and strategic
behavior avoid windfalls to bidders be
feasible to implement in an acceptable
time frame participation is voluntary
group payments constraint they were
paying attention to the core and
thinking about core selecting options
then it should be simple to understand
and participate and transparent which I
understood to mean easy to audit after
the fact essentially and those were the
those were the design goals ok 44 40 to
80 billion dollar auction so this was a
quite a project the what I want to talk
to you about is what the novel
challenges were in this design so
because the set of talks that we're
going to see involve research involve
innovation in basically four major areas
that will be talking about the first is
that the first area is that market
clearing this is different than the
standard theory of markets and the
standard theory of markets and in
economics you have supply you have
demand you have people buying and
selling the same thing so and you have
wheat you have people selling weed you
have buying people buying wheat you find
a market clearing price where supply
crosses demand here despite the public
think that these guys are just buying
and selling radio spectrum there
not buying and selling the same thing
the television broadcast rights look
very different than mobile broadband
rights they both use the same resource
they both use the radio spectrum but
they have very different interference
properties they have to be paired in
different ways the rights are actually
completely different and what has to
happen is we have to buy broadcast
rights and cell broadband rights and
convert them in between and we have to
buy roughly the same broadcast rights in
every part of the United States in order
to create a band plan that works with
mobile phone so it's not one good that
we're buying but a collection of
complementary goods and we have to
convert them into licenses for broadband
in a highly nonlinear way so it turns
out the TV broadcast licenses are these
little six megahertz chunks of spectrum
and mobile broadband licences are 10
megahertz chunks of spectrum 5 megahertz
of uplink and 5 megahertz of downlink
and depending which frequencies you buy
you can create different licenses in
different ways so we have this this
problem of figuring out what market
clearing should be that's novel and
auction design and we conceive of it as
a production problem in which we're
buying inputs and selling outputs the
second problem is that the production
problem is computationally hard I saw
Kevin's over there I saw Kevin come in
the finding TV channels for stations
that choose to remain on the Air not
sell their rights is like a graph
coloring problem but with extra
constraints we have you have to assign a
TV channel 2 i'll tell you more about
this in detail in a few moments you have
to assign a TV channel to each station
that remains on the air so that no two
channel adjacent channels channels that
are too close are assigned no two
adjacent stations are assigned to the
same channel no two adjacent nodes are
the same color it's a like a graph
coloring problem but with extra
constraints of various kinds domain
constraints or certain channels you
can't use near the Canadian border in
certain channels you can
near the Mexican border and and there
was some adjacent channel kid I
described to you the main constraints
the so-called co-channel constraints or
other constraints too so it's similar to
a graph coloring problem it's an
np-complete problem or class of problems
but it's not a graph coloring problem
formulating feasibility is a SAT problem
as Kevin did I understand involves about
600,000 constraints so it's a large
scale problem and we'll have to solve a
lot of these during the course of action
in real time so this is a if Kevin gets
a chance to talk it I don't know when
when you're talking out here but the
talking about the computational
innovations that were done to make this
something that we can do is is one of
the elements another element is to
encourage participation bidding to sell
needs to be easy a lot of the
participants in the auction the people
that we thought were most likely to sell
when we were doing the design were small
broadcasters who own you know that they
own channel 34 in Detroit or you know
channel 27 and Atlanta and they're
they're small businesses that you know
it's their life business maybe they have
a couple of channels in a couple of
different cities but they're small
broadcasters not huge they're not AT&T
and Verizon they have to participate in
an auction it's got to be easy for them
or they won't participate they have a
real option of not participating and
saying gee will let the big guys
participate and we'll sell to somebody
after the auction if we're going to sell
it all and if they don't participate we
won't be able to clear very much
spectrum or we won't be able to achieve
the objectives of the National Broadband
Plan so shenmue Lee's going to talk
later today about what it means for an
auction to be obviously strategy proof
it's going to turn out that if you try
to explain this auction the auction
we're doing two bidders which involves
these thousands of np-complete
calculations and say trust me its
strategy proof just report truthfully
that doesn't fly we don't think that
everybody's going to say gee we trust
the government that much that will just
report truth
bully it has to be not just strategy
proof but obviously strategy proof and
Shengo will tell you more about that
dumb later then the auction algorithm
itself needs to perform well it turns
out that this is this problem is too big
to do optimization in any way if you did
optimization what would you what would
you tell the bidder is how would the
bidders bid so we want to the auction
algorithm which doesn't involve the
optimization has to perform well in some
sense and Ilya will talk about some
elements of what that means in his talk
later and I'll talk about some elements
of what it means in my talk now ok so
the I want to talk now about the for
just a moment about the production
problem being computationally hired so
this is the graph of the interference
around one station so you see here a
station in the center of the graph each
node in this graph is a UHF TV station
each arc in the graph is a pair of
stations that cannot be assigned to the
same channel the when if you think about
this as a graph coloring problem these
are the main kinds of constraints that
we have and you see quite a bit of
complexity though other nodes in the
graph the white nodes that you see here
are things that are within to two steps
from the from the central node it's it's
a pretty complex mess and this is a
spring-loaded graph showing the overall
us interference structure you can see a
little bit in this graph the spring
loading I think you guys all know what
spring loading algorithms are you try to
pull together things that are connected
you try to push up part things that are
not connected and reveals something of
the structure of the graph and you can
see a little bit you can see that around
cities there's this is going on in here
too but you can see it out here around
cities everything interferes with
everything else you know we have some
number of channels in New York City and
if you have 20 channels 20 stations in
New York City no two of those can be on
the same channel every every one
interfere those are clicks in the graph
every one interferes with every other
but
there's just this huge mass of things
that are that are connected in a complex
way that make this say a hard problem to
solve in principle the auction will
probably need to solve more than a
hundred thousand we don't really know
yet but it's going to need to solve a
lot of these problems and it's going to
need to solve them in real time okay the
third thing I want to talk about is
market clearing being so this is all the
introduction introductory part with long
introduction but the overall scope of
what the project is it's a big project
that's been going on for several years
the the market clearing involves a
production problem so how are we going
to do market clearing okay now
conceptually I'm going to do this in two
levels for them i'm going to start off
first with the idea that somehow or
another spectrum is uniform which it's
not but just to give you conceptually
what what the concept of what the idea
is so what we're going to do is based on
the applications to participate in the
auction we're going to say what's the
largest number of channels we could hope
to clear suppose we decide you know we
can clear 126 megahertz of spectrum they
each that's 21 channels each Channel six
megahertz so we set up a quantity target
in some way are out of sight there is we
think of there as being like a supply
curve which is this upward sloping curve
here and a demand curve which is the
downward sloping curve that is if you
offer this is the usual economist thing
quantities on the x-axis prices on the
y-axis if you offer a higher price you
are going to you're going to get a
larger larger quantity supplied but a
smaller quantity demanded so that's
that's what the what the graph shows and
what we'll do is we'll announce that and
we'll start an auction in which prices
fall in the reverse auction gradually
and rise in the forward option so they
fall and rise and what we discover here
is G we can't clear that much because
the price we're getting from the buyers
in the forward option is less than the
price we're paying to the sellers in the
reverse auction we're suffering a loss
so what the algorithm is will say gee
that was too ambitious we will reduce
the quantity and let the price in the
reverse auction continue to fall and in
the forward auction continue to rise but
we still have a loss and then we'll
reduce the target further and we'll let
the price continued to fall in the
reverse auction and continue to rise in
the forward auction we have a revenue
target we have to meet we have to pay
the broadcasters who stay on the air
have to retune they'll have retuning
costs roughly two billion dollars we
have to raise two billion dollars in
profit at least to cover the the
relocation costs of the of the bidders
who don't sell their spectrum so we have
a net revenue target done and there's
some other restrictions here too which
I'll wait but that's roughly the concept
this is what economist called Marsh
alien dynamics where the where it's
adjusted in quantity and letting the
forward the the buy price and the sale
price adapt to a quantity to find the
defined market clearing the actual
process looks like this it's very
similar this is the graph from the from
the FCC's notice there's a reverse
auction in which prices fall a forward
auction which prices rise but there are
different prices for different stations
in different parts of the country it's
not all one product still where we're
trying to clear some number of channels
in San Francisco Chicago Los Angeles New
York Boston everywhere and and we have
these auctions going on which I'll
describe in some more detail there's a
cost associated with those we have
forward auction which we're selling
licenses in different parts of the
country there's revenue associated with
those and the the concept is exactly
what I showed you a moment ago ok ok the
yeah the targets global there's one so
we're trying to clear so your money for
Chicago to cover everything goes to the
country oh it in principle it's the
totals that matter your these devices
are set up so that they have to know
something about what frequencies they're
going to be using so we have to say you
know these channels are being cleared
for
uplink out of your phone these channels
are going to be used for downlink out of
your phone and they have to be the same
pretty much there's some filtering
things you can do but they have to be
pretty much the same across the whole
country I'm for simplification let's
just say they have to be exactly the
same across the whole country and so so
we're getting different prices and we
add them up we have perfect complements
if you will on the supply side and
perfect complements on the demand side
and it's the total prices that are being
compared but you said no reason I'm
asking is that you said that prices are
going to remove different in different
parts of the country yes what determines
i will show you we're going there okay
so they will get there so I'm trying to
give you right now an overview of what
the what the challenges were in the
design what the research challenges were
what kinds of solutions were coming up
with and then I'll talk a little bit
more about the researcher yeah and I see
the demand side compliments I don't see
the supply cycle well so in order to
clear channel 27 that suppose I want to
cheer Clear Channel's 31 251 for example
then I have to have that much free
spectrum in every city in Chicago Los
Angeles Detroit that's the supply side
okay so so I have to buy channels no no
it's not this it's us the the FCC in the
in its production problem the FCC's
problem these are perfect complements
right there is a clear which way you
move like and then you say you have the
core spectrum from force to 50 megahertz
which we know in this direction to move
to expect or is that also now so we've
so we've decided that in advance we're
going to we're going to clear down from
channel 51 channel 51 is the highest
channel it's currently used for
broadcast television we're going to
clear some set of channels down from 51
part of what makes this nonlinear by the
place so the as you as you clear down
there there are guard bands that you
have to put in between the uplink and
the downlink
then at channel 37 is set aside for
medical devices and radio astronomy and
if you clear down below channel 37 then
you need to the production involves
putting a guard band above and below
channel 37 it's it's really very
nonlinear the the conversion from from
channels cleared to to broadband
spectrum created one city in the United
States no one wants the Pacific
participate then everything goes the way
or there's a way for cinema say first no
but what you know what so the okay so in
the simplified version i'm giving you if
that happens the we wouldn't be able to
sell in fact another one of the
challenges was how to deal with that and
we have and i'm not going to talk about
that today but that's a separate
challenge the the way we're getting the
way we hope to get people to participate
as the part of this design as the
opening prices are very high they as
when we announced the the tentative
opening prices you know where all these
people said oh there's no way we'll sell
our television station this is our
business we're Fox were a fox affilliate
we're an NBC affiliate in to sell these
stations and then we post the tentative
opening prices nine hundred million
dollars in Los Angeles you know was a
kind of opening price people nine
hundred million dollars and and imagine
you have a station in Los Angeles and
this is over-the-air television so you
need to know that in the United States
ninety percent of people get their their
broadcast signal either through cable or
satellite and so even if you got shut
off you'd still have ninety percent of
your customers left we're talking about
ten percent of your customers nine
hundred million dollars this is
completely outrageous everybody is
interested Fox's interested CBS is
interested everybody's interested at the
opening prices so so we do expect that
we'll have enough interest at the
opening prices but it may turn out that
those prices are too high for AT&T
Verizon t-mobile and so on in which case
the process will continue but we do
expect to be able to clear almost
uniformly there's
areas that are problematic but almost
uniformly okay to encourage
participation bidding to sell needs to
be easy so that's what Shane was going
to talk about but but I'm going to tell
you just a little bit more about that so
one of the things that was talked about
at the very beginning was the
possibility of victory auctions you guys
all know what Vic reactions are but the
problem with Vickery auctions are a
problem with victory options is you
can't even estimate these prices
accurately so so each victory price is
the difference between two numbers it's
between the total value of the
continuing broadcasters with or without
one station it's the incremental
contribution of the station to total
value with 2,000 stations a one-percent
computation error in the optimization
leads to a on average of two thousand
percent pricing error and estimating the
victory price and including as we found
in the data with the FCC had lots of
calculations and we found a whole bunch
of negative prices where we'll we'll
take your station if you pay us for it
you know the because the you know yeah
we get big pricing years and you know
testing with cplex and grow be the best
guarantees that emerge they ran these
things for weeks attempting to do
optimizations the they had a team of
operations researchers formulating the
questions they got performance guarantee
they could guarantee ninety-seven
percent of the optimum after you know
weeks of computation it just this just
isn't good enough to calculate victory
prices even if they could be calculated
accurately your victory prices are going
to be awfully hard to explain to bidders
and for bidders to verify so Ava I I'm
gonna buy your station I've decided your
prices 10 million dollars and you say
where did you come up with that number
and I well I did this calculation Iran
gareau be four weeks I'm the government
trust me you know the it's just you know
and then explaining the calculation it's
really tough so so we've decided we
needed something different than that
again Sheng Wu has it has a deeper
treatment of this that you'll hear a
little later so we settled on an
alternative and an alternative greedy
based procedures which shall you'll some
of you have already heard about these
different acceptance options and the one
of the big surprises and this is what
the I want to talk about when i get to
the technical part but later today is
that how well this performed you know it
in in the 90s of percent of the value
that the optimization of obtained it we
got really high percentage percentages
from just a greedy procedure and that
was a big surprise and so it was a big
surprise because I so again I've learned
a bunch of stuff from computer
scientists I see all these worst-case
bounce worst-case bounds if you don't
have substitutes if you don't have the
right structure and your constraints if
your constraints don't form a matrix
case bounds are terrible right and and
here we're getting these things in the
90s if percents and why is that
happening so um ok so to explain the hey
Kevin there's my call out to you thank
you for letting me use your slides on
this the to explain the algorithm for
the reverse auction kevin has a
beautiful analogy which is airline
overbooking so the idea is that we have
we've already sold seats so to speak
that is we have stations that are on the
air we've given them the right to be on
the air we need to get them to give up
their seats to move off the year and so
Kevin turn this into an airline
overbooking example we have oh and i
will say will come a little bit more to
this if you're just thinking about
algorithms and you want to talk you have
a knapsack problem or something like
that you can think of the problem
putting things in the knapsack or
leaving things out of the knapsack you
basically just sorting things into two
groups subject to some constraints see
you don't tend to think algorithmically
if they're being a big difference
between putting things in and taking
things out but in economics there is a
big difference between those two things
because it's the bids
we accept the category that we call the
accepted bids those are the people that
get paid and the bids that we reject
those are the people that don't get paid
and so the incentives are different for
four algorithms where we decide who to
reject in a greedy fashion and who to
accept in a greedy fashion so even
though algorithmically you may not see
much distinction in terms of incentives
there is a distinction and well so you
may want to pay a little bit of
attention to that as we move along so
here's the airline overbooking problem
we start off this is if you like New
York Chicago Los Angeles we have or its
first class business class economy class
we have people who already have seats
and there's plenty of seats for
everybody thought somebody decides we
need a smaller plane we have to we're
going to use the big plane for something
else and so all of a sudden we have a
bunch of people that don't have seats
okay and the airline has to find seats
for these people and so and it's coed
doesn't have room for everybody so it
offers compensation it says a thousand
dollars I'll give a thousand dollars so
this is an auction I'm tentatively
offering a thousand dollars for people
who will give up their seat on the plane
and a whole bunch of people say great
I'll take a thousand dollars to give up
my seat on the plane and all these
people move off well now we have more
people off than we need there's still
there's empty seats with a thousand
dollars empty seats in first class
business class economy class so we say
oops we don't need quite so many people
we're lowering our offer to eight
hundred dollars this is our descending
auction and a bunch of people say oops
as well sorry I'm going back so we now
have a bunch of people back on the plane
and notice now that first class is full
so we can't afford to have any of these
people go back we need them so we don't
lower the offer to them we fix their
price at eight hundred dollars and say
okay you guys we're taking you your
price is eight hundred dollars but these
other prices are going down so we offer
six hundred dollars and a bunch of
people move back we still have space we
offer five hundred dollars more people
move back now business class is full
shoji we now these two guys we can't
afford for them to change their minds
we're going to freeze their price at
five hundred dollars they've agreed to
take five hundred dollars but we lower
the price to four hundred dollars for
economy and then to three hundred
dollars there's still empty space to 250
now economy class is full as well we
freeze the price at 250 and we have
different prices so this isn't partial
answer to your question this is only
part of the answer but we have different
prices in different parts of the country
based on who is willing to sell and
based on our feasibility constraints
okay here the feasibility constraints do
former mate right there really simple
and the and consequently this actually
and by the way if this is New York Los
Angeles and Chicago you see how we
determine prices for stations in each of
the different areas okay yeah prices up
during the process you know it can only
go down and they're going down by
smaller increments than I showed you so
right there's no chance that there'll be
too much demand d we process so it did
we actually process the station
sequentially one at a time and so the
what would what actually goes on in the
auction is over here when we lower the
prices from 300 to 200 to 250 one
station at a time during the processing
in the auction and if you are frozen
that is if we don't have space for you
while your price is still 300 then we
pay you 300 so we don't necessarily get
exactly equal prices for everybody in
economy class in our processing okay
it's actually sequential that way we
never overshoot okay so this now notice
that suppose this calculations were
complicated I have to figure out whether
I've space for you I have to solve a
graph coloring problem to figure out is
there any way to assign you a channel so
it's a complicated calculation
nevertheless you can figure out that
this is strategy proof for you I've just
offered you you know a thousand dollars
for a seat that's worth 350
you say you know well not maybe hello er
the price maybe he won't but I'm not
going to say no to a thousand dollars so
its strategy proof for you even though
you don't understand the algorithm so
that's a that's one of the things we
wanted to do it's obviously strategy
proof that's roughly speaking what I
said in the sense that Sheng Wu will
make precise its weekly group strategy
proof which means that if there's no
transfers allowed between the
participants there's no joint deviation
that any group of bidders can adopt that
strictly profitable for all of them so
unless the bidders collude make side
payments they there's no there's no
group deviation that's strictly
profitable for all the participants yeah
oh yeah well the so we say in practice
why the time is really ticking on me
here the UM can I take that offline
because there's all sorts of other
issues that have to do with channel
sharing technologies bidders who go off
here might choose to share a channel
then they have to be able to talk to
each other but once they can talk to
each other how do you stop them from
talking about the bids and the auction
so these things are tricky and we
actually did a lot of work on that
that's part of the economics that I
won't talk about today algorithmically
this is a greedy rejection algorithm
which is to say that as prices go down
what's happening is that bids are being
rejected these are people who are not
going to be paid they're moving on to
the plane rather than so what's
happening is that I am really rejecting
stations and that that's important from
it's not algorithmically important but
it's important from the standpoint of
analyzing incentives ok to run quickly
because time is really running off on me
call a set of bids independent if it's
possible to find seats or TV channels
for the rejected bidders in the airline
example the collection of independent
sets that I just showed you is a mate
roid just the
consequently this greedy rejections
algorithm does implement an efficient
outcome and consequently because the
Vickrey auction is the only strategy
proof auction that implements the
efficient outcome it follows that the
prices that are coming out of this our
victory prices I'm going to be I'm going
to jump over there's there some closely
related work in computer science and
economics the these guys though in the
overbooking problem it's the bids that
the option rejects not the ones that
accepts that a process greedily that's a
distinction of this from the previous
work but there this previous work as
closely related and I won't say more
about it given the time ok the auction
algorithm needs to perform well I have
only 10 minutes left so let's let's do a
little bit of this so for mere lines to
the FCC so our option is not exactly the
same as what I explained to you here's
the here are the main differences first
of all the price that's offered to a
bitter in any round is is not the same
for all bidders it's not just the clock
price rather it's the clock price
multiplied by some bitter specific
constant and that bitter specific
constant depends on the population
coverage that the bitter has and the
number of stations with which it
interferes so we are trying to to offer
higher prices to pull out stations that
cause a lot of interference there's a
knapsack like character we think to part
of the problem and we want to get rid of
the stations that take up a lot of space
so to speak and we don't want to overpay
small stations we think we can get small
stations to to exit for lower prices so
we take into account the population of
the station and making the offers this
that's a if you like that's a price
discrimination trick that's built into
the design and that's probably the wrong
language to use but we're offering
prices that are dependent on the on
population the thing I want to talk to
you about i guess the technical piece i
want to talk to you about is approximate
mate roids so what I've learned from you
guys when you know
when I hear about algorithms is if you
don't have one structure let's try
another structure let's move away from
gross substitutes to sub modularity to
something else where you go from one
structure to the other and you know it's
an economist the way the economist tend
to think about this is a little
different than I wanted to see if I
could formalize that that I wanted to
think that this idea you know it's not
substitutes exactly it's not a mate
right exactly but maybe it's close to
being the mate right in some sense is
there a metric that tells me how close
this thing is to being a matric that
tells me how well a greedy algorithm
would perform so that's the kind of way
I wanted to approach the problem because
if I don't want to say as soon as you
take one constraint that kills the major
I'd structure that it greedy algorithm
won't perform well so given a collection
of independent sets see the goal is to
uh to find a larger collection which
I'll call the outer bound mo4 outer and
a smaller collection mi which is the
inner bound with MI and see in MO and
then to build an auction that's
equivalent to running a greedy algorithm
on em I find the optimum for that overly
constrained problem and then relax the
constraints to continue to fill see now
if mi and mo are close to each other
then they're close to see I know that
the greedy algorithm gets me an exact
optimum on mi that the greedy algorithm
gets me an exact optimum on mo that the
value of mi n mo are closed and
therefore I would be getting an
approximate optimum for C and if I could
met rise the distance between am I and
on em oh I would be telling you
something about how well the greedy
algorithm could perform ok so that's the
general idea and with only a few minutes
that here's a here's some hierarchy
based mate rides and the reason that I'm
using them so I'll say that a collection
of so I the ground set G like if you
like the set of TV stations or the set
of passengers and I have subsets of that
and that set forms a hierarchy if for
any two elements any two sets in the
collection
either ones a subset of the other or
they're disjoint so that was the case in
the first class business class coach
example that we looked at a moment ago
i'm going to say given some notation
given a this hierarchy and given any
function from the hierarchy to the
natural numbers including 0 i'm going to
say that mfh so this is a that might
going to be my mate right approximation
using this function h and this bound
this function f in this collection H is
the is the collection of sets such that
sets s such that the size of the
intersection the number of elements in
the intersection of s with b is less
than or equal to F of B for all be in
the hierarchy ok so that's a hierarchy
which is defined by a bunch of
inequality bounds this is a set that's
defined by a bunch of inequality bounds
and the and the theorem is for this
collection of sets mfh is a Maitre as a
major ID for all functions f if and only
if this collection H is a hierarchy ok
so this is a so the reason I'm using
hierarchies is that when you impose
bounds in this way this is the if you
impose bounds in this way and you don't
know what the bounds are going to be in
advance you want to determine the set f
you need the collection H to be a
hierarchy ok so given a family of
independent sets in a hierarchy I'm
going to define a bounding function this
way I'm going to let B of s be the the
maximum of four for all T in in my
collection of s intercept T so by
construction c is in EM of H and be so
the the by I've taken this bound so that
it's just big enough to to not constrain
anything that's actually in the the real
constraint set and then I'm going to
defy so that's for my outer bounding set
that's going to give me my outer bound
and then I'm going to
find biro of s to be i'm going to take
row x this outer bound and where Rho is
an is enough that if I shrink the outer
bound enough I i get an inner bound on c
and i'm going to use row to measure how
close i am if row is 1 then the original
set is a hierarchy and therefore is a
mate right and i'm done and if row is 0
i mean some row will work 0 will always
work here because the if I'm if I don't
impose any constraints I'm fine so the
I'll always get an inner boundary values
for each item you can then apply the
standard greedy algorithm to this inner
approximation relax and continue the
greedy algorithm and what you'll get is
that this this algorithm obtains at
least a 1 minus Rho star fraction of the
maximum value of the problem with these
constraints which is the outer bound
constraints and consequently with the
actual constraints the so optimizing
just on the inner bound gives me this
fraction 1 minus row of what i get if i
optimize them the outer bound and since
the actual constraints are between the
inner and outer bound I must be getting
at least 1 minus Rho of of the actual
constraints as well ok and the point is
then that there is a deferred acceptance
there is a descending auction where I
descend prices separately to each
station where I do it in that way so
that I'm greedily selecting the stations
in MI and and then continuing to reduce
prices to continue to apply the
constraints in C and so there is a a
deferred acceptance auction a descending
price auction that implements this and
it's obviously strategy proof in the
sense that sheng was going to define for
you a little later ok and i don't really
have time you can also mix metroid so I
what I really want to be able to do this
is all research and progress is mixed
may
rides and knapsacks and in a greedy
algorithm this is a not a particularly
good description of what goes on in the
FCC problem but it's my first attempt to
mix a mate right and knapsack
constraints so imagine that the ground
set is partitioned into a collection of
items g1 through gk and that i have
associated mate ride constraints within
each one of these ground sets and i have
sizes if you will i probably should have
used exercises but WK is the size of a
station in in ground set k and suppose i
have this additional knapsack like
constraint so the idea is that in the
FCC auction some stations cause a lot of
interference they interfere with a lot
of other stations stem stations cause
very little interference let's imagine
that that's a characteristic of the area
that the stations in stations in detroit
or stations in chicago as i say this
isn't necessarily a good description of
the real FCC problem but suppose that
that's a characteristic of the stations
in the area and suppose that if I that I
fail to be a major right only because of
these other constraints that if there's
if there's not too much interference
that I can find a coloring then I can
use a the the kind of greedy algorithm
that's used in the knapsack problem
where you look at value precise
respecting both the knapsack and the
Metroid constraints and suppose that you
stop this wastefully the first time that
the knapsack constraint causes a
rejection if the remaining space in the
knapsack at termination is Sigma then
the algorithm performance is at least 1
minus Sigma over K it's the same bound
that you get from any knapsack problem
but instead of the items all being
individual I have for each item i have
another group of metroid constraints on
them so this moreover there is a
descending clock auction that implements
this algorithm so I can run a clock
auction that achieves good efficiency
and respect simultaneously a knapsack
type constraint and matron type
constraints ok so the object is to try
to explain
good performance in a certain class of
applications as the white why does why
did the maitre d constraints make sense
will remember we had these in the in the
airline overbooking we had first class
business class coach in the in the in
the radio spectrum allocation problem we
have Chicago which is a which is to
click all those things interfere with
one another I can have a constraint that
if I if I have 15 channels available I
can't have more than 15 stations in
Chicago I have a lot of constraints like
that and to the extent that those are
the most important constraints on the
problem I can hope to that some kind of
greedy algorithm in this class will will
perform well taking those constraints
into account so that's I'm almost out of
time so i guess i'll stop here and take
questions just before we went to the
macaroni something on the fact the
clocks of the prices are running
differently for different stations yeah
right now I can understand that is
mostly different so there is a fairness
issue here that perhaps let me go to
court and challenge what you're doing
now they cannot challenge is also
different markets but two stations that
is exactly the same area one is in 27
and one is in 35 and 35 is much more
problematic because of the other of the
other constraints why should they be
paid 1020 service paid 500 where they
are making exactly the same profit that
the same coverage you just so you know
your intuition about what people will
challenge is completely wrong the that's
not nobody challenges that part
everybody understands that what the FCC
needs to do is to eliminate stations
that are causing interference that keep
it from that keep it from clearing as
much spectrum as they like the
challenges that came up were the other
kind where people said gee
you know you need me just as badly as
you need him how come you're paying me
less just because I serve a smaller
population you know it's so the
challenges are actually very different
than the one you mentioned the FCC's a
governmental entity and it has a if you
read in the report and order it it takes
the all the comments into account there
are people that challenge it and there
are other people that say well you know
other TV stations that say you know
population coverage is one of the main
things we use in figuring out our
evaluation so that seems appropriate and
the FCC says we've looked at comments
from both sides and we've decided to
keep the rule that we proposed so that's
that's what the report and order says
okay so it's it is not through the two
stations who are identical but just
happen to build different channels they
will go for different prices because we
really they can be retuned so the
initial channel really doesn't matter to
us and so if you have to station they're
exactly identical have exactly same
coverage and the exactly same
interference contains any possible
channel where they might be assigned
then we would be offered exactly the
same prices up for this one detriment
because of the you know random process
injured Vega guys yeah so you heard a
different question than I heard so just
to reconcile these two things the it's
not that they're on a different channel
I heard you saying they had different
population coverages the same population
coverage oh then it doesn't matter what
channel to run because we can we can we
can move them into different seats no no
it's it said there it said they're there
the number of inter stations with which
yeah but that's not that's not
determined based on the channel that
you're on that's determined based on the
channels you could be on because we're
going to rear reassigning everybody's
getting new channels we have to take
everybody who's let's say if we clears
channel 31 251 everybody was on a
channel above channel 31 will be moved
to and stays on the air will be moved to
a channel below channel 31 and to make
room for them we have may have to move
some other people around to you don't
have a right to the channel your
on you only have a right to a broadcast
channel in the UHF band no population
the actual number of yours that they
have over the know that the population
that's covered in their service area the
service area of all stations and
approach is not the same now you know in
Chicago these stations are all
broadcasting from the top of the Willis
Tower and if they if they tune their
antennas in the same direction though
they'd have the same coverage but the
you could be in a different location the
the local the antennas are partly
directional they did that because at the
time they were setting up they didn't
want to cause interference with somebody
else so they tune their station in a
certain way so they start with they can
start with different population
coverages only when the option starts or
after that no it's we know it now they
have licenses now no no no no no they
have a license now that tells them what
what area they're intended to cover
without interference that broadcast at a
certain power without interference in a
certain area that's all fixed yeah yes
absolutely right so the we design this
auction with the small broadcasters in
mind if you own multiple seats in the
same area that is in in the overbooking
example if you learn multiple first
class seats or multiple coach seats or
multiple business class seats in other
words field on multiple television
stations in the same city then you do
have some market power and it's not
strategy proof and we were designing
with the small broadcasters in mind to
make it easy for them it turns out that
most of the big broadcasters own only
one station in each city but there are
some places where this is a problem and
and market power is a problem for us in
those places yes you cannot always more
than 20 stations in each market now by
the FCC rules also if you own to you may
not necessarily consider selling both of
them you know Matt you might want just
to sell one and that's
so the cases where you want excise
market power where the choices self to
purchase to sell one they might happen
but then from your local area code so
what you lose is I would have solved to
but I'm going to draw one of them back
in time to get more for the elephants
yeah that's that's the that's the risk
guess we're both thank you everybody